yeah I got [ __ ] up in the Nam okay we
are yeah I know you are okay we're back
Rick Wilson will there be negative
consequences for Republican politicians
like Christie chris Christie who have
endorsed Donald Trump
well Christie gets to fetch a shine box
every day when Donald Trump summons him
that does look and and he is a guy and I
think a lot of these people are gonna
pay a price for it and I think that I
think that that Donald Trump is not a
transactional politician he's all about
the bottomless ego need of Donald Trump
and that's why anybody who's endorsing
him they're thinking oh I'm going to get
something out of this I'm gonna get an
appointment I'm going to get some some
favor from Trump know when he's done
he's done with them wrap that moment on
the airport tarmac where he said good on
the plane that was just that that was
the coldest death I've ever seen in
politics okay Bernie does Bernie Sanders
have a realistic proposal for Wall
Street Reform I think he has more
rhetoric than reality actually Hillary
Clinton has a very specific and detailed
proposal to use some of the powers that
are there in the bill as the New York
Times editorial said I do not think that
simply saying break up the bank look I
just did a piece they don't tell us them
what - what low-level you need to do it
and in fact we have in the bill powers
that have not yet been used and no I do
not just talk about the dodd-frank bill
yeah I even you are the Frank in that I
know but the only I don't say that so
you know something about it I was yeah
but you're the only person in history
who could refer to himself in the third
person and not seem like a pompous jerk
with shoulder golf so I never I never
refer to myself but if the point is what
I've seen I book carefully at what
senator Sanders you said I by the way he
was there he voted for the bill I don't
know he was in the Senate when we passed
the bill and was very supportive of it
but I have not seen specifics that go
beyond what we have done there okay
Esperanza what can you tell us about
your work with Frieda slaves oh well I
didn't know slavery was so prevalent so
that sorry slavery still in the world a
lot of it actually yeah
it is amazing and horrific and in our
own backyard and a lot of the products
that we are acclimated to using its
shock so when I heard about that I said
okay I want to align myself with these
people and folks are listening to me
I'll buy them what countries are we
talking about where is it worst worse in
India and Bangladesh what happens almost
everywhere I'm sure it happens
everywhere personally there's all sorts
of forms of slavery on recive gourdel
yeah yeah it's Saudi Arabia
yeah what do you think about Obama
criticizing them in the Atlantic I
amazingly about time about time about it
right yeah that was a pretty stark and
that's a pretty stark real time somebody
did in America and I think we're I think
we're all I think there's a bipartisan
moment where we're getting past that
infatuation right so okay I know that I
need to listen yeah Michael well just
have my leverage yeah very limited
leverage with who
Saudi Arabia but I think we have more
leverage than ever because we don't need
oil like we used to we are the leading
oil protect a Jew but we you have proven
yourselves impotent in the Middle East
we have a real I mean yes we have use
more noise more impotent than Saudi
Arabia it's their own backyard and they
won't even send troops to kill Isis well
what are the ones who should be doing I
why are we doing pine bills to kill Isis
there for foreign Hammond we don't want
to get the middle of this do you trust
me yet I wanna know smile into a meadow
not look you know we've never have left
we've never get compliments all night Oh
Mike shut up and gather the way yeah and
where were you earlier
hey goddamn now look we've never had
less influence in the Middle East than
we do now you know and we are not the
words for it I do not write that this is
America's role it's not our need and
ossible for us to bring pieces so I
don't ever get energy politics I'm not
talking energy
get energy poncho somebody no wooden
ring go hard and go now you know that's
what there are people dying there and
you stop it my dear what can we do to
stop we can't sweet bugger all what
virtually nothing I agree virtually
nothing but you know what it works when
we try you know we're so many wife
you've contributed so much to this
problem and it's washing up on all our
Shore I'm only too moral responsibility
what it would make it worse I enter with
the wrong body night right I don't think
we can do how about a little we're off
love right it's the Republicans are
always for personal responsibility what
about personal responsibility for all
those countries that are surrounding
Isis who say they are enemies of Isis
but we don't make them fight Isis why
are we leading this coalition they have
planes I know we sold them to the in
fairness those the support of Saudi
Arabia has been a bipartisan fact of
life Sharon tree performed by Lovelace
or so I don't know I know I'm just I
want to make sure that it's not just on
my part okay right now it falls on a
soul that falls on us all the bush is
the ones who actually held hands with
them literally but but our willful
refusal to understand the deeper stories
of what's going on in the Middle East
our misconceptions are thinking that
it's just the way we want it to be I
mean we should just plain stay out we
have no idea right we only make it worse
yeah and you know the reason why we
don't is because we always have two big
ourselves up that we're the
indispensable nation and we're not it's
Russia well they're not either I do
anymore
dude Putin just played us all for fools
no he didn't
hey it was a masterstroke huge me but
pains eptein you're a putin fan I'm I'm
a huge Putin fan if you are in survival
power politics totally cut
yourself you acknowledge that we have no
great interest there and then you
complain that we didn't do anything
there's nothing that we could accomplish
and nothing that hurting had complement
at least 30 nineties after Putin is
after a secure naval base on the
Mediterranean and a new will do with it
and what he's secured it and he's a
Jesuit and he's got in and he's got out
with relatively about a call you have
more bases excuse me let me finish we
have more bases in the Middle East than
he does and they don't act how does it
help America and how does it help him to
have one neither one of us Sherman tanks
is Mediterranean blue and we have one
Holies are very easy for y'all that's
all you man avatar if I may call gone
with the wind stuff would you share all
right
it's but wasted time and money for both
of us all this now has is cotton and
arrogance sister Simone I can do all
have done with the wedding masa masa
yeah let me read you scarlet the only
thing worth fighting for what's done for
the kids don't know God ones all right
now seriously awesome sister Simone do
you think that the coalition of
religious support for Republicans will
start to break down if Trump is the
nominee well that's it well I think the
religious support for Republicans has
broken down period regardless of who the
nominee is because what's happened is
that the fact of the more progressive
thought that it's seen more as an
integration of all of the questions not
just sexual questions become the
questions that we ask at this time the
issues of income inequality the issues
of the disparities in our cities and
towns the issues of racism are at the
heart of religious conversation and that
is changing how America embodies faith
and how faith is involved politically
it's broken down period
question because a lot of a lot of
Evangelicals who are supporting Donald
Trump who in previous eras would have
been absolutely rigidly opposed to gay
marriage absolutely opposed to abortion
they're like woo Donald Trump so what
we're doing it it's all about Trump and
and this is this to me as a sign that
that the evangelical part of the
Republican base has to do some
self-assessment and decide if they
really believe in the things that they
want to be a definitional for the party
for offend them for a second doesn't the
Bible say render unto Caesar what is
Caesar's they're saying look we're not
voting for a preacher we have a preacher
we're voting for a president that's a
different position their historical
thing of disqualifying people flat-out
show who believed in in gay marriage or
who believed in an abortion right was is
suddenly completely gone with Donald
Trump well we're not completely but with
a large faction a large part of the the
evangelical and correspondence between
Donald Trump and much of the Bible and
marriage and that is it's okay for a guy
to marry a lot of women the Bible says
that's okay and Donald Trump says a leg
of a right yeah right and one after
another area like I'm yeah right and
Saudi Arabia
we love Saudi Arabia and you know and in
order brides in Laden was the 20th of 55
children it's always the middle kid yeah
all right thank you very much everybody
your regret audience
you